[Music]
five for their first eight from downtown
miami's best plays from last year and
that was bam adebayo
setting the screen to set up duncan
robinson with the screen assist
the michael jordan of delaware gets a
bucket as lonzo catching shoot time he's
got the first five points of the game
you know drew holliday has been nothing
but class
uh from the time that he's been in the
league and from the time that he has
been
bucket from the time that he's been here
in new orleans yeah he
that was uncharacteristic you and i both
know that uh deflection stephen adams
otherwise anna nobody's got an easy dunk
inside
so there's steven adams in his link
lonzo ball cleaning it up
he's got the triple
[Music]
you keep that basketball in front of you
it's a lot easier to
to defend that 3.9 lonzo ball
gets the triple brings it up from his
shoe tops
off the lip of the rim zion gets it out
in a hurry early offense
lonzo gets another triple ball solanza
now three of six from beyond the ark and
he's in double figures
and boucher has it taken away he thought
he had it
looking for early offense and lonzo will
go with the triple
he's got another hells by six their
biggest lead of the game high
39 from three a season ago
nearly had a triple double in new
orleans season opening win against
toronto
ball will try from deep end hit on the
delivery from
ingram and you want to talk
lonzo thought about it now we'll get it
okay he has it so what happens is
now you attack the rim a couple times
you drop one off the stephen
sons have started 406. and here comes
lonzo ball
in that big trade for anthony davis and
his three is away and good
now shot clock coming down and brandon
knows it
gotta go and lonzo will nice look
lonzo ball a lot of second chances from
him so
i'm happy that kenrich is getting some
run hitting some play not much but a
little bit
lonzo how about a deep triple got it
that's big the only 83 shots last game
is zion tried to get into the paint
extra pass lonzo from bledsoe good
basketball sharing the basketball
and a six-point lead also jackson a
stays on the floor
it'll be lonzo catch and shoot gets the
triple powell's needed
it's been a dry spell mellie on the
baseline
i thought adams was going in that
direction
lonzo a three ball got it
[Applause]
brandon ingram going hard against ingram
shares it though and it pays off lonzo
with the bucket
switch sides real quickly and what a
spin
it'll be lonzo ball for the lead corner
three got it
brandon ingram again though
that's a good split of the double team
by bi that's good patience
jj and he's clipped on the way by stays
with it
and lonzo what a break a three are you
kidding me
how did it get there to begin with it
doesn't matter what they say about you
ride's about to hate young man
eventually is it'll balance out
well they come in 30th and three-point
percentage right back exactly
lonzo ball with the triple he's gonna
get better yeah he has a lot of
potential right
corner threes available lonzo step back
three instead
he's got that down over dial
[Applause]
here's lonzo ball from outside and he
drains it falling the other night
in salt lake on tuesday in that 118-102
win
there's a shot from outside lonzo ball
that is a good sign
minnesota with a lead and that was a
great pass
by a kogi lonzo ball they gambled can he
burn them yes
pels needed it leading by two once again
now you're down 13 again with only two
to play
lonzo ball behind a wall answers
so it's back to 10. but jerome robinson
a former pick of the clippers
and he's working for a full-time gig
it'll be lonzo ball good luck he's got
the truck really good basketball
eight boards last night in his first
career start
lonzo they walk away and he makes him
pay yes
here is ball who malika andrews informed
us just moments ago is playing without
restriction tonight
despite that ankle injury on wednesday
and ball buries the three
ball in with ingram hart
are you you got it back in
yep and ball buries the three
vincenzo can't hit from three to begin
the second half for milwaukee
here's zion kicking ball hitting
from downtown the pelicans pick up right
where they left off
zion lost it adams dives for it
shot clock fading ball left alone
shooting practice you bet
giannis going to get a brief breather
here
from mike putnalzer ball corner three
is good alonzo ball
with seven threes tonight well just
think of it
the other night against washington he
turned his ankle
he only played 16 minutes he was
questionable as spartan
steven adams with zion
it'll be lonzo catch and shoot picks up
where he left off
seven threes last night like you said
picking up right where he left off
yesterday
he plays a good role for them in fact
he's in the top 20 in offensive rebounds
in the league
he's got 11 offensive boards over the
last four
lonzo ball catch and shoot look good you
know i'm a big percentage guy
now you got chris paul on the switch
guarding zion so ball
takes the three and hits it and it's
tough
you think about it mark the sons have
not made the playoffs since
2010 as ball drills a three
[Applause]
you see right now since the sun's going
into his own
and lonzo ball starting to feel it now
he's three for five
so zion is going to get it and a little
weave out front with brandon ingram on
the dribble handoff
alonzo catch and shoot yes that's a good
that's a good
you can shoot over him he'll skip it
instead lonzo corner three
got it that's big that's a serious skip
by brandon late
they're trying to find sides paul goes
to the other side to brandon ingram
he's got the small one it'll be lonzo d3
got it really have to look at your
match-ups excellent read by bi
and this is why you wanted lonzo to
shoot the last one this is exactly why
when his feet are set
and there's no indecision his efficiency
is through the roof
eric bledsoe back into the game now
eight on the shot clock for the bells
[Applause]
lonzo step back three big
man man he's got three triples over the
last four minutes say it again that's
big
not just save your tillman but everyone
else that's going to help
bledsoe skips it well at a deep triple
picks up right right exactly inside of
10 on the shot clock
brandon ingram sets it up lines up more
time
and the perfect result beats it in his
hands more
in pick and roll being a facilitator
making plays for himself and his
teammates
he gets kicked to the outside new
orleans retains
hart swing it to a better shot and ball
cans it scrapping for it gordon couldn't
take it away from alexander walker shot
clock is down to six
kick ball got it a three
he's hit at least two threes in 16 of
their first 23
lonzo boy four-point play he's going to
the line looking for the four-point play
the difference look at his feet when his
feet are set and he won
twos into that that's his first miss
from beyond the arc
five of six from beyond the arc for zach
levine
lonzo a deep triple yes on the back on
the night of a back to back we have to
get on the plane and travel
ingram and lonzo ball waiting
on the wing man is he on a roll what
good reason is there to play the anthem
before a game
and when someone tweeted him saying i
love mark cuban stan replied agreed
and that's the sentiment some of his
players feel as well 12
for 23 is dallas from three-point
territory the struggles guarding that
line continue for new orleans
certainly seen him in rhythm so far
tonight with six threes in that first
half
marking a career high and a half mark db
he was in rhythm in a big way cassidy as
ball fires from deep
and connects on his third three of the
night that conversation that cassidy
mentioned that
mark cuban gave him saying hey i believe
in us
they were hit hard and early by covid
but boy starting to round into shape
dallas mark jones
former first round pick of the raptors
so he knows dwayne casey very well back
in 2015 taken by toronto
it'll be alonzo didn't rush it let him
fly by
he did steven adams lost the handle
but another opportunity second chance
lonzo ball
a bounce in rhythm yeah and i like
getting ready that he took his time
getting into the paint where he's so
effective
blenso low dribble kick ball launches
got a three the balance of when to pass
and then when to attack
good die that's the way to kick and
london
there's a drastic difference between the
last shot that lonzo took
and that three-point shot right there
nazir little five of five last night
three or three from beyond the arc
lonzo catching shoot time yes and you
know what i like i like bi coming out
and being in
kind of a facilitator role right now to
billy who was in the dunker spot
then penetrate your man turns his head
lonzo sliding over getting this
eric bledsoe trying to find a handle
lonzo top shot
gets it anyway into the shot clock he
beat it
brandon ingram hesitation move lonzo's
got the look
and capitalizes pells by one
trading punches with 90 seconds left
opportunity again for aiden
he didn't waste any time a lot of touch
now you got the floor out of balance
now you got a four on three opportunity
it's about making the right read catch
and shoot
lonzo's got it so they don't have a post
threat
deep three lonzo man
timeout monty williams my mechanics are
different
so now you got to believe in your
ability to shoot that ball that is a
confident shot by lonzo ball
[Music]
he'll blow by eight and share it well
lonzo catching shoot time
good ball movement yes it started with
bi breaking down the defense
kicking it over josh
it'll be lonzo into the shot clock yes
three plus to play three-point lead and
now booker getting into it poker
that took away from his game i thought
in the brooklyn matchup it'll be lonzo
he's got space
got the triple that's a good job by b.i
taking two with him and then making the
correct
goes beyond that for me it's the spirit
that he embodies that has an impact on
the guys around him
williamson goes quick on thompson kicks
out to ball
ball putting in work with fred vincent
on that three-point shot
and he did a good job off the bench for
them in the first match up in 12 minutes
against the bells lonzo ball
don't leave that man filling it up don't
leave that man open
if you don't stop them in the paint
they'll throw it out to their shooters
but you have to build that wall first
lonzo ball who's played so well as of
late early on he
sort of duke zion said he handled the
ball quite a bit as a
as a youngster and they have been
benefiting
from his ball handling and i love five
point lead for the bucks
and while we talk about that five-point
lead ball is trying to take it up to
eight and he does right there
just under two to go here in the first
ball for three yes
ball hitting the three adams is checking
anthony i don't know why that would be
the case
because zion can definitely stay in
front of him
better than adams after the foul on
bates diop that's her fourth team foul
lonzo fills it up bells back up by a
four bledsoe
double clutch gotta go shot clock down
percentage buster for lonzo got it
that's big
gives him another chance the back tap
and the same story
lonzo now got it at the buzzer
so a three-point loss evens the season
series
after a three-point win at home donovan
mitchell could have easily took that
shot
here's ball that's that adjusted
mechanic to his
jumper that would have cut it to single
digits
as wonderful minutes bledsoe from deep
splash
[Applause]
lonzo step back triple got it
he feels pretty good
[Applause]
miami back up 11 as we come to the end
of the first half in new orleans
all step back three it's good
to get back near 500
ball for three got it
ingram sets a ball
it's called a power play isn't it yeah
skill bully ball
alonzo's got a clean look makes the most
of it and the bells are up by 10.
it's gone lonzo's free if you want him
he found him good call finally falls
pels now three of 12 from beyond the arc
8-nothing run out of the timeout
for minnesota bledsoe caught in the air
but lonzo's free
he's got the three and you needed that
because minnesota came out in a zone
now bledsoe going by quinn cook and
shares it extra pass lonzo clean look
corner three yeah what that is
you already know what that is 61 on the
board
[Applause]
all into the corner now here's ingram
paul's been shooting it well from
downtown and knocks down
his first three zion being guarded by
batum and the
clippers switch bledsoe into the corner
ball another three and he's two for two
from deep
if you're coaching the pelicans now
you're very happy mainly because you're
holding them to one shot
they're shooting and missing and now
you're making your three ball
six on the shot clock for the pelicans
gotta get to work here
good pass to ball and he hits the side
pocket three that's his
fourth three-pointer already here in the
first half
early touch here for ingram spread the
floor lonzo ball
work the high post ball the jump shot
he's a different guy reggie
off the heel slapped out of there by
adams
bledsoe the drive and kick ball ready
position bottom a three
[Applause]
both teams at 38 from beyond the art
68-57 new orleans
it's ball the timing
brandon ingram up against covington
bledsoe shares it
good pass alonzo gets it it'll be
brandon thinking about a three
in this year little on the second chance
opportunity you gotta go
bledsoe sees it good pass really good
good lonzo's got the triple brannon
ingram
here's lonzo fall and the d3 yes
big brings it down to a nine-point game
alonzo is among the top 10 of the league
in steals
first three since back in it nothing's
changed looks pretty good that's right
he's 6'4 but his wingspan makes him feel
longer good catch
jackson lonzo free on the arc back to
back he's got a couple of triples to
start jackson hayes credit
for bringing that basketball steven
adams good to see you back out there
wood
and it's taken away eric bledsoe got
involved no space on that side
leaving it james johnson it'll be lonzo
quickly keep it up and jackson hayes the
three-point threat jackson hayes
you know the post alonzo four for four
yes
keep it up they're gonna review it
so originally they said three then two
gonna be lonzo
yes alonso is now five of seven on his
triple good job by james johnson
really good job nobody stopped the
basketball lonzo free he's got a three
and it gets it pels needed it and a
timeout for steven savage shot by lonzo
i always just brought a cake myself
five-point game 57-52
it'll be lonzo ball finally there you go
[Applause]
burger has a really nice game on him we
talked about it with now lonzo
he's not backing away there you go you
don't stop shooting
you don't stop shooting pass jackson
couldn't give him a dime
and nigey marshall alonzo get it back
wow top three
that's really a tough ball away
zion against jeff green lost his footing
got it back out to ball
ball looked like a long two
boy you've got joel embiid trying to put
some pressure on the mvp voters and
steph curry
at an obscene level shooting the
basketball
all right they played golden state three
times down the stretch golden state
is in ninth there in the 11th so very
interesting to see how it transpired
stan van gundy saying he hasn't been
able to find the right mix just yet and
holding himself accountable as well as
his players
well i mean the challenge shoot is see
along lonzo ball able to step back and
knock in the much needed three for
repellent
yeah they bring it back out bledsoe on
the run out
sharing it with lonzo good luck corner
three
it is contagious when that ball moves
from hand to hand so first
you got to control derozan and second
you got to be ready to make plays that's
exactly what i mean just like that
that's being ready to make a play now
continue to execute offensively
you got a couple stops in a row lonzo
they went under the screen burns them
down
timeout right and again anjo hasn't been
shooting the ball well lately
but there's no hesitation right there
you love that hell's cut the lead to two
you can't go into the locker room down
by double figures
zion shares it beautifully lonzo wide
open gets the triple
it's a good three yeah zion with the
dribble and the
driving kit it'll be brandon ingram on
the road
lonzo step back triple got it
big eight point game and a timeout for
san antonio
i tell you what i like his
aggressiveness i love how aggressive he
is
now if you can get all three guys at the
same accord
this game can change now bledsoe off the
adam's pick
little bit lonzo catching shoot he's
been hot it continues
fifth triple berlinzo baldi's five of
eight from beyond the ark and he leads
the bells now put a little low
on the run out yes that's what he does
he got back took it away from amir
coffee
now floor is spaced alonzo available
he'll take it he'll get it all right
zion to go help and leave his guy and by
the way the bells have ten threes
now it's matched by the ten threes of
the clippers make it eleven
yes lonzo he's now two or five from
beyond the arc
he lives in the right corner doesn't he
he knows his sweet spot
now lonzo step back three yes
tells right back at it and trailing by
only five
and bledsoe taking advantage of the
little guy gets it right back
never touched the rim though lonzo yes
back-to-back triples brandon and lonzo
jokic is a legit seven-footer and you're
right
it'll be a deep three for lonzo they
walked away and he got him
time out because they're going to get up
and down the floor
lines are coming off the pick with the
pop and it looks pretty good on the
triple one point game
three minutes plus gone by so the pels
have it back starting the game three for
eight
and making it four for nine i like the
fact that those are two confident shots
you can tell they made the proper
decision when they took them first
overall wiseman
second la bello ball though that's the
conversation and another triple
find that man keep it going
now zion shares it lonzo hot hand
he's got it again no hesitation he's
three of five from beyond the arc
so he's got a double double lonzo free
on the arc again
gets it this is good dying on screens
doesn't do a lot of good
that's 23 already for anthony edwards
he's had a career best 42 lonzo's on
he's picked up right where he left off
at the first half
so nasreed gets the triple and now
minnesota
has a two-point lead their biggest of
the game lonzo
he's got it matching the career best in
threes and you can see ricky rubio
marshall four seconds left marshall
driving
finding ball gets rid of it in time it's
good lonzo ball with a big
three before halftime to give new
orleans a little momentum
currently stands in the western
conference and also a preview of game
two of our
doubleheader tonight with the nuggets
and lakers eight nothing run by new
orleans to end the first half
time to weld off the glass and on the
run saw that coming brandon
good steal lonzo available ties it got
it
it's nice to see him knock one down too
out of the timeout lonzo good save
gets the triple he's got his first two
and and even though the pedals
are now four of 16 shooting they're
really good shapes
yeah be deliberate and there's lonzo
showing him he's got some range
once again draymond green with that one
and bazemore lost it
take advantage of it brandon ingram
pulled the chair out on him
lonzo in the corner he's available ties
it up
got it even at 50. i tell you what he's
shooting that thing today
y'all can say whatever y'all want to
about that young man he believes in
himself
seven or nothing runs for the pals he
believes in his skill set
that knocks down the three-point shot
and he's stepped in with confidence
right that's
he's got 12 boards eight dimes it's all
even
so did he with an answer
now zion lonzo equalizer
he's going to get him it's going
soft for him he was the guy that went in
the trade
indianapolis wanted him that badly he
won the trade for the 15th overall pick
of the draft bag here and it turned out
to be kawhi leonard catching shoot time
alonso gets the triple
so yeah but i'm looking away oh okay
i have a rear view mirror out of the
time outlanzo ball
makes it a two-point game yes sir he
could handle a two-on-one
in tight space like that eric bledsoe
and lonzo free on the wing how about a
three he's got it
it's been a struggle for lonzo
ball back in for new orleans
rookie lewis to ball
he's shooting a heck of a lot better
this year the lamello has been fouled
while
making a shot from the field and he's 19
years of age
and not finished growing older brother
lonzo hits
lonzo ball two in a row
five-point game two-and-a-half going by
and the opportunity there
lonzo deep triple got it how about a one
possession game now after the pals were
down by 12
to start the third